all right I'll try it again I'm going to
open the uh subcommittee work session on
house Brill 1410 thank you and um I want
to talk a little bit about you know how
I'd like to go through this uh there's I
think nine sections in this and they're
uh very quite different things um and
I'm not necessarily going to go through
it in order what I'd like to do is take
care of some that I think are going to
be pretty
straightforward and then we can talk
about um what we want to do with the
rest and so the subcommittee will
probably end up um recommending an
amendment uh to the full committee and
it could do different things to
different parts of the bill
so um is everybody fine with that I yeah
I just had a quick question sure um I
see sections that are struck out so was
this a bill that came last term and and
kind of came again no the sections that
are strike struck out they're striking
out current statute okay because this is
changing current statute it's not
relative to some prior Bill okay and uh
the other question I had was the
numbering you said nine sections so
there's lot of delete
reignment um so I just want to kind of
if you can just go through what are
sorry yeah the the Arabic numerals uh
that are the most to the left but I I'll
I'll go through it and I'll tell you the
page and line numbers that would be
great as because I have enough trouble
following
this
um
so what I'd like to deal with
um first is um there's a number of
things which I think are
just doing things like we're done last
session with moving uh certain functions
from the boards uh to
oplc um that weren't done for everything
some things got missed and so I'd like
to deal with those first and I think um
the first one in here is on page two
starting at line
23 uh nurse practice at act powers and
duties of the
board and um I'd like uh somebody from
oplc I mean we let other people come up
if if they want but if you could come up
um Doug and
uh you know I'll I'll try and explain
what I think is going on and tell me how
I'm
wrong which is which is like and you can
both you know introduce
yourselves good afternoon Douglas so how
general counsel for oplc with me is
Bethany catrell she's the division
director for licensing and boarding
Administration okay thank you for being
here but again again we'll look at uh at
section three powers and duties of the
board and um what I'm seeing is it's
doing things like on line 28 moving you
know the the actual exam the licensing
and renewal from the board to oplc as we
did with many other things um similarly
uh moving some of the disciplinary uh
action out and um getting rid of some of
the stuff on having to maintain the
records and all that stuff and and also
dealing with fees um and so this runs
through this was section so this runs
through line you know line 20 on uh on
page three is the part we're talking
about and you know am I correct is it
doing something more than just the same
stuff we did last time no it's the same
thing it just brings it in um and
comports with 310 at this point
establishing those roles and
responsibilities but there's nothing
here when I read through it that
shouldn't be or that surprised me in any
way okay does anybody on the
subcommittee have any questions for them
about
that so this is currently
existing uh so oplc has
the correct operates or functions are is
responsible for these functions okay
sorry I'm trying to get the a little
history um last year there's this we had
this huge redo and there's I think 57
boards and in general there were you
know each board did a lot of
administrative functions themselves the
idea was to move a lot of those into
oplc make it more efficient and and
organized and all that and it wasn't
done for everything and this is this
section is just trying to doing part of
that for um nursing for the nurse
nursing yeah thank you any other
questions
here is there anybody who else who' like
to speak on this section
up if you can turn the mic on please
yeah thank you good afternoon my name is
Susan buckton I'm the state long-term
care edsman yeah and I just had a couple
of questions related to what you just
said when I look at this section it
appears to me and maybe this is more a
clarification you're saying that it
moves processes from the boards to oplc
the authority right correct that's my
understanding yes so when I look at
starting with line
23 it's
amending 326 B4 the powers and duties of
the board to establish eligibility
criteria for lure and renewal of lure
including examination requirements and
continuing ed
requirements
so yeah that's what's currently in the
nurse pra this
act establishes those criteria in the
nurse practice act so Doug if you could
come up please um yeah I was wondering
about that one
I doesn't the language for other boards
say something about like in consultation
with the board or something like that
well here the board would actually have
the authority to establish these
criteria so basically if you wanted that
sound bite it would be oplc controls the
process but the board controls the
criteria so the board would establish
the education requirements those types
of things but the application would come
into oplc we'd run the checklist did
they meet the requirements established
by the board so I think as I understand
it there's a section that struck out on
line 28 so the the actual issuing of the
licenses and handling renewal is done by
oplc corre but this leaves the board
criteria right is that and I and I I
agree with that but when I look at the
you know
page bear with me a minute so page six
uh this is no that's past the section
we're talking about but we can look at
it if you want well because it relates
to it yeah sure so it
removes what line so
2099 2930 and
31 particularly 29 and 31 talk about the
cus it talks about those
criteria and and it removes the LNA
portion of CE criteria actually what
there is if you look at section one
which we're not dealing with at the
moment I want to take separately because
I know it's controversial um that
removes LNA uh licensing and just leaves
it with the
certification and so as part of that um
you know those would have to be remove
but I've got some notes here that some
of those repeals are tied to the LNA
thing so let's say we chose not you know
to delete the LNA dropping the LNA
license and some of these repeals would
also go with it and so I'd like to take
those together at least unless I'm
missing something which I may
be I have a question on that one I
represent Mani thank you uh Mr chair uh
the N it also refers to the National
Council of State Boards of Nursing for
identified
so if this is
deleted
how will that affect will there is no
RSA tied to that uh I think that that's
not
being touched um so Doug that language
um on on lines 25 and 26 on page two I I
didn't go line by line with the RSA in
this but isn't that language that's
already that's currently in the RSA so
what they did is they what OSS did when
they drafted this is they took RSA 2
326b 4 and they copied it the whole
thing and then they made the changes in
it but the the parts here that are not
in bold which are added and not struck
through our current statute so that's
not changing
okay any other questions from the
subcomittee
okay uh thank you Mr chair and for those
at the
table and for you
what you said I don't think is what I'm
reading the
replacement language that's in two
establish eligibility criteria for lure
and renewal Etc that removes that from
the nursing board no no no I think what
it does is it it explicitly grants it to
no it does say powers of the board the
board May okay and and because before
under the what you what it used to be
on three yeah no go ahead yeah I'm sorry
I mean we can we can run it really
formally we can be a little if there's
line1
exam
actess
yeah right and the parts that struck out
on line 28 was before the boards were
responsible to actually you know examine
license and renew the license of the
individuals and and that you know the
Machinery of running through the process
is in oplc but the board will still have
the authority to establish the criteria
okay thank you certainly um can oplc
tell me will this red one of the biggest
uh questions I get about is the time it
takes now you know the process so
by taking that process away from the
nursing board will that cut down May
basis everybody's Calling My Name
by I'm going to ignore ignoring them uh
for
now so the the authority to process the
license is actually transferred to the
office on July one of last year so we've
been doing that process and I well
bethan you might be able to answer it
better but for one what I understand it
is sped up the process and we heard
testimony on some other bills yesterday
that said it has sped up the process so
so far as far as I know it's been a
success positive change okay great' and
if I could just uh you know
make sure I understand that that
basically um you've been operating as
though this change had already occurred
because we gave you the authority last
year I mean is the board issuing they're
not issuing the licenses no we're doing
that oplc is doing this so in effect
this is already been this is the way
things are being done and we're just
straightening out statute so when we
originally introduced 655 I think the
bill was about 120 some pages long and
and representative groa did you know an
enormous amount of were so this this
would be some of the conflicting
language that we're still addressing
okay thank you and and if someone could
comment answer uh represent mti's
question about if somebody could if
you're done you if you want no no no she
I want her to up on micop I think my my
question probably comes later to your
point thank you okay okay and as yes if
someone can just answer the question
timeliness thank you Bethany Katrell
again
um so the way that the process is now
working is that because the boards are
able to set that eligibility criteria
and then oplc is doing the operations of
that instead of a if an applicant sent
in their application previously previous
to this change it would be reviewed and
then sent to the board for review and
then approved or denied at that board
meeting now based on these eligibility
um requirements and objective criteria
with the collaboration of the board were
able to approve or deny those licenses
prior to a board meeting happening so it
could be three days it could be a week
it could be 14 days but it does not have
to wait for that board meeting unless
there is um a requirement for a subject
matter expertise at that time it would
go still go to the
board can I just ask follow yeah so it's
simult parallel processing so while the
opl see is uh looking at the process of
granting or renewal board is looking at
the requirement and uh they set those
requirements prior to um yeah but they
will be reviewing what the applicant
status is with regard not the
application
itself but requirement if there's an
issue with the application that would go
before the board still correct thank you
but am I understand they they set the
requirements and then that's
automatically works for for applicants
unless there's some exception or issue
so what one more last certainly yeah
what is the time frame that we are
talking 14 days four
weeks it's really hard to set a number
um because it's based on when we receive
a completed application so uh it depends
on if someone sends in all of those
requirements or if they just send in
pieces so it's been very hard to
quantify that um if there application is
complete and they meet all of those
requirements it can be done within three
business days um but it depends again on
what that time frame is but that is the
goal of the executive director in our
strategic plan within the next two is
years is to make sure that we're around
that time frame based on completed
applications and I also want to point
out that while we're typically well
ahead of the time frames there are time
frames in RSA 541 a29 and 29a that sort
of of set parameters for us as
well
and represent Brown yeah yes uh thank
you Mr
chair so the criteria that exist in
number one and the elig elig yeah
eligibility criteria that's in the new
number
two are those
different so is the nursing board now
I'm going to ask another question before
follow up before I get an answer
is the nursing board setting the
criteria for what you need to become
licensed yes and is that not the
eligibility criteria that's on line
29 um so if you're looking at line 25
and 26 that's referencing the National
Council of State Boards of Nursing that
is the national membership organization
that sets be best practice throughout
the country and so that um section there
is basically saying that the board will
stay in um collaboration with those
National best practice standards and
then if you look at two about
establishing the eligibility criteria
that is stating that the board will then
set the administrative rules for those
um requirements for applications um and
lure for nursing got it thank you just
to clarify the rulle making Authority
starts on page three line 22 and uh line
24 specifically references ibility
requirements for initial temporary
renewal of
licenses Okay I uh uh yes representative
uh
G thank you Mr chair I just want to make
sure um that I'm following from our
previous work together if I and and
please correct me if I State this wrong
so that's my question do I understand
this correctly as I understand it there
was previously boards doing all this
work the office of
Licensing became established and slowly
has has responsibilities have moved and
there was a lot of discussion a lot of
turmoil across a lot of different boards
about what parts of the work the board
did should be transferred and and so
what we're seeing here the language is
really clear the board will and the
section we're talking about now is
laying out what the board will still do
and the board still is exercising all of
their technical knowledge to establish
criteria and I don't mean this in any
demeaning way but basically the office
of Professional Licensing is doing the
clerical kind of tasks and they can do
it because they work 9 to5 Monday
through Friday in a more timely fashion
than the board that has to figure out
when everybody can get together and meet
and you have applicants that are peac
mealing things in which further
complicate the timeline but an office
from 8 to five can handle those pieces
better is that sort of what we're
talking about yes exactly thank you just
also on the timeline thing um what we've
heard testimony before from U executive
director that they're working on an IT
solution where people will be able to
submit their applications online and the
and that system will tell them whether
or not they've included so they're not
going to submit a partial one it'll tell
them you need this this and this and it
won't actually go into oplc or the
boards or anybody until all the pieces
are there and instead of you send it in
and maybe I don't know following it days
or weeks to get back oh you're missing
this piece you do some round trips and
hopefully that'll be gone I mean it
could add a frustration to you can't
download you don't know what you're
missing but that's that's a a technical
challenge but with regard to LNA we are
focusing on LNA tied into no that's a
separate this is a general nurse
Practice Act this is all the nurses the
LNA one is section one one and I know
there's going to be there's issues with
that okay sorry yeah that's okay okay
one last question with the nurse Board
of Nursing how often do they
meet they currently meet monthly unless
there's a need for emergency or special
meetings okay that's Doug I one further
question and that is related to section
three are um are any of the repeals in
section 10 really
specifically tied and necessary as part
of section
three um you know there's a number on
326b but I think most of those probably
are related to the LNA licensing but I
it was I don't think there's any related
to section but I if you could
check I can see is the RSA 326b for
these are 19 20 20 16 19 and 21 there's
totally 326 DB colon 16
326b colum 19 I didn't see any in the
section we are addressing two and three
right relating to that I was hoping
there wasn't a reference that it was
okay thank you that we don't have to we
we can treat them separately that most
of those are for the LNA and I know
there's some in that whole section for
the radiation stuff and that
registration and all that but
as long as if we want to keep Section 3
unchanged you know is there anything we
also have to say in section 10 we need
question
and I'll probably have similar questions
yeah yeah I'm just looking over it real
quick uh I don't think so is yeah I
looked I didn't either but I thought you
know you're the expert
so thought I'd ask okay uh does anyone
else want to speak on this section
section
three
okay so thank you um my name is Samantha
O'Neal and I'm the chair of the Board of
Nursing
welcome um thank you um there's one
component that I just want to make sure
um as it relates to the process of
application so the Board of Nursing has
worked collaboratively with oplc where
the board has set the criteria and we've
worked with oplc to say here are
parameters in which to work from so we
can make the process smoother and more
efficient so you don't have to wait for
a board meeting but if there are
applications such as like background
checks that have issues um inappropriate
um conduct or so forth if somebody has
been um uh disciplined in another state
those come before us to look at because
those are outside of the parameters that
the board has set for oplc so we work
collaboratively together to make sure
that that process is faster and
efficient to get people their license
quicker thank you any questions
uman py and then
Brown so when you thank you for taking
my question and and when you say Board
of Nursing RN
LPN APN APRN APN RN LPN LNA and
Mna which is the medical nursing
assistant okay so you're responsible for
all of them correct okay represent Brown
yeah uh thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question so I will translate
that if I might into the you're okay
with this wording
of the new number two three well section
three number
two sorry section well Ro Roman Roman
two it should be yes I'm sorry section
three Roman two yes okay thanks that's
that's easy thank you is there anybody
else that wants to speak on section
three okay see none what I'd like to do
and and we continue doing this as we go
through is take kind of
a an informal vote of the committee and
and the the question is uh keep section
three in the bill um as is and and uh if
you want some discussion that's fine and
if not I'll I'll accept a motion yeah my
sorry go ahead if you I leave to you
repres just uh just the thing is like as
long as we are cutting down down the
process time making the process more
clean streamlined and it's a
collaborative effort so there's
collaboration it's not on one shoulder
this one board's responsibility no I
mean yeah I think they're working
together well and it's part of this
whole we're trying to do this for all
the boards and and there are pieces that
were left out and so it's kind of like
we gave the authority to oplc and we
still left certain ones with the board
and it it there's a conflict really
makes sense thank you representative
G I move that we accept um the changes
in this bill from line 23 on page two
through
line um 20 on page three 20 make 23
to page yep that's correct I'll second
that
okay yep doesn't the section two it has
to start on page one
no no I mean the page numberers at the
top yeah page one that's I mean there's
the title page which count title page
two all of section three under the what
the nursing board may do and line 21 on
page three starts with section four
nurse Practice Act and that'll be a new
section that is not part of what we just
discussed okay so as I understand it uh
well I know you tried to make a motion
first did you yeah that's that's fine it
doesn't matter that's I apologize I make
an motion I thought it was a
question you had the detailed once for
this one up uh representative Gould and
brown seconded it I believe and then uh
everybody agrees I anybody anyone oppose
okay unanimous five to zero Good Start
okay um so we're done with that section
I'd like to go on I think the next one
we do would be uh section
four um which is gets into the um the
rulemaking Authority
for um the nurse Practice Act and
um Mr AER house if you can come up um Mr
Sher so that is Page Three line 21
correct y thank you um so looking at
this and again this is a correct me if
I'm wrong my understanding is that um
it's I've seen this Lang this language
on uh page three line 25 a lot where
it's it's uh moving the
responsibilities you know some of these
things might be board the but a bunch of
them oplc it just moves the language
from from by the board to under this
chapter so they're put wherever the
chapter says they should go and then on
the next p and by the way this thing uh
section four ends on page four at line
28 and the rest of this is keeping the
language the same except for the
addition starting on um page four line
24 and
um and it talk that where it talks about
42 CFR the federal um Reg regulations
lnas line 24 through 28 on page four it
does apply to the lnas in the nursing
registry but only the
lnas okay
[Music]
so um what i' I'd like to you know again
any questions for anyone here about that
yes representative G and representative
Brown then y I mean man py and then
Brown um so this Federal Regulation only
applies for LNA National Registry is for
LNA not for
[Music]
nursing I'm sorry can you repeat your
question I I said I'm just curious uh
the national C 42 CFR is only for LNA
general yes so that is a federal
registry for licensed nursing assist
assistants and um m&as the
medic
m&as but it's the registry of nurse AIDS
is if you look up that
CFR so to clarify it's lnas and m&as you
need to be an LNA to become an
m& and one more followup certainly thank
you we we don't have CNAs in New
Hampshire but this is a national R CNA
is also in that certified you mean
certified nursing assistant also part of
uh I think well yeah somebody else can
do and and there's section one of the
bill deals with that to some extent but
which we'll get to go ahead Elizabeth
eaten board counsel to the board of
nursing um so the federal registry is
for nurse AIDS in New Hampshire we call
them licensed nursing assistant or
medication nursing assistant um an m&
has to be an LNA uh it it only applies
to nurse
AIDS is there a second part to the
question so in other parts of the
country CNA could be part of that CNA is
what some other states call
lnas we we happen to call them
lnas um
so what um oh let me ask one other
question Doug if we were to eliminate um
section one not saying we will but if
were to eliminate section one uh related
to removing the licensing for
lnas would it uh should this part here
uh page four lines 24 to 28 should it
remain or should it be removed I I do I
want to make a point that under the
licensing definition for 541a and in RSA
310 the registry is still considered a
license so we're talking about removing
the license for r r lnas but they'll
still but if there's a registration they
are still technically licensed by the
state and that that's an important
important dis I know there are people
who are concerned about that at the
public hearing but but the just a
technical question if we were to get rid
of the license for lnas which is in part
one should this section on page four
remain or not yes we would think that
that would remain in in order to meet
the federal requirements and to maintain
a registry because they're still going
to be registered even if we don't have
what's an official right and this would
allow us to add the renewal ability for
the registry and those other pieces that
would go along with that okay any other
questions uh representative Brown first
this time thank you Mr chair uh to to
either one of you so the on line 24 the
implementation of the nursing assistant
registry so I think from the first day
of
testimony that that means that New
Hampshire will
be picking up managing that registry for
our nurses that will be on it we can
access that registry and that's what I
understood from the first day but that
could be totally wrong yeah who who who
go ahead go ahead if you want to clarify
how do the whole process you need me to
clarify the coordination between the
federal and the state registry so we
maintain that registry currently at oplc
and so this would just continue that
registration okay and and followup
actually follow different question
and there was some concern the first day
of testimony about differences
in requirements to meet the
certification versus an LNA New
Hampshire I'd like to address I'd like
to address the actual licensing part
when we deal with Section one if that's
okay okay and I'll represent Munch py
thank you Mr chair so help me understand
this if we remove the LNA
licensing
provision that will impact m& because
you have to be licensed nurse assistant
and in order for m& who administer the
medication that is needed so we
cannot technically remove LNA licensing
correct
if you can answer if you have an answer
I I I mean so I think what we're trying
to do once if if the state requires a
registry under 541a that's still a
license but the situation we're in right
now is that an individual can pass those
competency programs or evaluations and
then they get put on the registry and
then there's this potential Gap because
there's a separate process for becoming
a an LNA licensed in New Hampshire which
is that $35 in the application so I
think the goal maybe what we should do
is is move to section one and then we
can come back to section four and that
might make things easier uh she's still
got a question she's looking an answer
for but uh what why don't you address
the whole you know in context her
question then we can so I think the goal
here ultimately is to streamline the
process once the
individual uh passes that competency
exam the state is required by the cfrs
to put that person on the registry
within 30 days so essentially that
becomes initial licare there's no
separate initial application and there's
no other period or and there's no $35
fee but it's still if we require an
individual to practice to be on the
registry that would still be a license
and we'd still be able to require CES
two-year renewal under RSA 310 those
types of things so what this does is it
kind of streamlines the the process in
the first
instance clarification certainly thank
you so that clarifies so see if the
central registry is just a database
where you get the pass and so if I want
to practice as an LNA I should go to
Next Step get the license then if I want
to become an
m& further get that
today
no right that's when I have that's how
it is now that's the process as it
stands currently so what's removed in
this so this process would be saying
that if a um if I went and took my
course to become an LNA that the state
would have um statutes and rules and
regulations that set up a registry so
that way when I pass my course I get
onto that registry and based on the
current statutes that's considered a
license here in New Hampshire and then
would allow us to set um renewal
requirements for the registry you would
not have to then do an additional
application initial application and pay
a fee and then maintain both because
right now the way it is is that an LNA
has to maintain both a registry and um
and the application this would just be
streamlining it to be a registration
if I if I could ask a quick clar
clarification for myself so right now
let's talk about right now the whole the
process
of uh of the federal
registry and or the federal you know CFR
that and our we have a registry set up
now and we require if you want to be an
LNA the first thing you have to do is
meet the requirements of that CFR and
get in our registry so is that whole
part of it going to stay basically the
same so that's not changing it should
stay the same yes okay if we were to get
rid of the license requirement and so
the LI you know so they do that first
and then they apply for the the state
license as opposed to
registration and um other than paying
the fee are there any other
requirements believe there's a criminal
background check that's required under
the current application that wouldn't be
required once because the CFR says once
the individual passes receives that
their exam whatever they are
automatically placed on the
registry so there is a difference in
that piece on the can I get
clarification on the criminal background
check we could be a little I mean okay
if you're okay with that yeah are you
saying that if we eliminate the second
duplicative licensing process and we
just go with the registry we don't have
a mechanism for a criminal background
check
we do not by eliminating this
duplicative
process before I answer that question I
think there was an additional thing I
was unaware of if I could let board
counsel y go
ahead so in addition to the background
check there's also uh in New Hampshire a
higher level of educational requirements
including a higher level of clinical
practice um before you graduate and and
complete your program
that to be my question and related to
that is there any difference in the
scope of practice that you have today if
you've got the registration and the
license or if we were to do this just
the
registration that seems to be a point of
contention I would say no because the
state gets to set the Practice Act but I
think there might be people behind me
who disagree with that answer no from
what I understand sorry Mr chair I
jumped yeah we can
beay in in order even if you practice
like if a high school student is doing
the LNA track heon and they get 20 hours
and they can do another 20 hours total
of 40 hours of training before they
apply for license to practice as LNA in
New Hampshire correct so is it the same
as National Registry or National
Registry has a less are um uh hours the
National Registry does have fewer hours
required for both classro and clinical
experience um to to answer your scope
question it really differs by state
because State can regulate the scope of
practice certainly And to clarify on
that too uh the state can also set the
standards for training and
competency okay
um is what's
proposed
M microphone go right from the registry
to m& you don't need the license right
when you were on the registry you would
be in LNA but how do you become the
m&a there's a separate application for
an m&a right but do you need the license
which is proposed to go away no no
problem
solved representative Brown okay going
back to the question I started asking
before and it's been made more confusing
to me
so it it sounds like what the the person
from The Board of Nursing said there's
more hours and more clinical as it as it
now stands than the federal piece if we
go to this registry do those
requirements go
away how where are they managed so it
would not be that they go away but
that's the section that we were talking
about prior to going here um on page
four line 26 to 28 that's what I was
going to ask back then so that's the
that we were saying would still stay in
that there would still be a requirement
for the Board of Nursing to set
requirements for a nurse aid training
and competency evaluation program that
would be pursuant to that so that would
be the place where you'd be able to set
those requirements okay so let let me
sort of follow up to that thank you so
if we if we passed section one and we
got rid of the nurse license would
what's here online 4 24 to 28 let uh the
New Hampshire board and
oplc basically put in the same
requirements on training and and maybe
scope of practice as we have
today that's the way I read it yes does
anyone disagree with
that the only the only thing missing
here that I can tell is the background
check and so they can do the competency
they can do the evaluation all of that
but um there's no implementation of a
background check here
okay just to finish this I mean if we if
we wanted to if is that true there's no
background check and would there be any
problem putting somewhere in here saying
they had to have a background check
thank
you we might have to add two right
background check and renewal so once
they get on the reg Ren here it's I am I
sorry we a little free form but not too
much so first of all let's do the
background check one it so right now
there wouldn't be a requirement the
problem is if you have to automatically
put an individual on the registry when
is the time for the background tracks
but let me follow up on that if you're
saying we can add additional training
requirements it would sound like we
couldn't do that if you have to put them
on the background check when they meet
the federal requirements or is that
incorrect thank
you my understanding for how they go
onto the registry is that they would
have to pass a course that is approved
by the Board of Nursing or pass the
competencies that are approved by the
Board of Nursing and then they would be
put onto the registry and so then that
would be their license but because there
isn't something a time or an application
in between then the background check
would not be able to be an additional
requirement it would have to be set
prior to in those educational and
competency requirements but can we do
that if we don't have the license and
we're just doing the registration my
understand my understanding is yes based
on how we approve what educational
programs and competencies will allow
them to be put on the registry so it
wouldn't be that yeah go on correct it
wouldn't be that someone in Wyoming
would finish their LNA and be put on the
New Hampshire registry so this is this
is the New Hampshire registry that's
based in Federal requirements okay so
uhu I one thing I want to bring up and
that is I had a discussion with
representative grota before you know at
the end or I think it was yesterday and
I guess she has a bill which is to deal
with nursing I think there's some uh
Comm committ some study and maybe an
actually Bill to do things and she was
um
suggesting that we take the section one
out and that she she could deal with it
in that and the reason I mean I told her
we'd start looking at it and see what we
thought because it sounds like probably
we're okay but it's sounds a little
unclear because what the question the
real overarching question is can we get
rid of the license and still have the
lnas that are certified only have um at
least similar training and scope of
practice as today and also somehow have
a background check as today so that's
the question are we can we really be
sure the answer to that is yes I think
the background check comes at like the
employer employee level so I me I'd be
okay with that but see if other people
are comfortable without the requirement
but my couple of uh questions I have
is background check is to make sure the
TR you know transitional nature of the
communities now you know I could be here
today I could move across the country
and that's an easy one so the background
check and if there is no requirement to
renew my license or you know who's
keeping track of my continuing ad once I
get the registry and I'm
fine where is the checks and balance as
we are asking them to take care of I
think it needs to be clear that under
541a if you're placed on the registry
that would be a license as long as we
required that registry so then we could
make a renewal process with the CE
requirements and all that and maintain
those as we go every two years it would
need to be
renewed that that would make it
more solid in terms of what we are
providing for care for our constituents
who need this care that we are
overseeing the quality of care through
whether you call it licensing or renewal
registry but there should be a oversight
by nursing board or oplc that would
still exist yes that will still
ex again just to reiterate it if if we
were to leave section one in and the
repeals that are in section 10 related
to this
um you know you could it'd be done
through rulemaking but you could have
basic with the same training
requirements um you could require
require a background check and I don't I
mean you mean if if it's required for
the registration do the employers then
do another one or would there be some
value to having one and if you move in
New Hampshire you're you're covered I I
don't
know the process the process currently
is if someone has to have a background
check through oplc uh to get their
license then that stays with us if they
then need to have another one through
their employer they would have to do
that again and so be the same if there
was a registration and and we added a
requirement so you wouldn't be able to
add a require to the registration you
would not be able to add a requirement
of the background check because there
would not be a time frame or an
application for them to be able to do
that so I think that's what board
counsel was also saying and I I believe
there are people that might want to
testify separate to that sure um so what
we are saying is that it in this field
tends to fall on the employer to do
those background checks so if we were to
remove the license type and just have it
be a registry which under 541a is still
considered a license it would remove the
initial requirement at lure for
background checks and place that
requirement on the employer would the
would it actually place the requirement
on the employer or the expectation the
expectation uh I can tell you as an
employer of a home care we used to spend
hundreds of dollars on background check
physical and they would you know we had
to pay for the training then they got 5
cents more someplace else we couldn't go
back and I would say ask us we'll give
you the background check don't spend
another money but they don't because
it's the it's the owners on the employer
it's the burden on the so maybe you can
answer this and other people so today
because the lnas are required to have
the background check as part of the
state license do the employers not spend
the money to do a background Che of
their own to get their license it's the
uh lna's responsibility but if they want
to get employed then the employer has to
do it again that's on the so it is
already being done by the by both really
exactly so it's duplicative basically
okay I think I think it depends on the
employer oh okay yeah uh representative
uh Brown okay uh two questions for the
nursing board folks
on on page four the the two new sections
15 and 16 it was just said that that
covers the difference between a registry
now and the Board of Nursing
requirements now that those two sections
allow us to have more some more strict
requirements than the registry I haven't
read through the CFR but I don't read
the English in those two lines as saying
that
it's everything except the background
check so the background check is our
biggest concern okay so so all right so
everyone in the room is clear that 15
and 16 means the Board of Nursing can
have some extra requirements on top of
the registry that's what I want to make
sure and there's a hush in the room so
we're
good second question and I apologize for
being
blunt if we don't have a background
check are we saying that elas and if
there's a person that has uh elder abuse
that we're okay giving them a license
that's the problem sir so yesterday we
had a board of nursing meeting we had
four hearings all four hearings were
based on background checks for lnas we
approved two we denied two 81% % and I
this was in my testimony last week
81% of LNA applications come before the
board for criminal background concerns
and so we have specic specific criteria
that we hold near and dear to make sure
that the community is safe employers now
my background I'm the public member and
the chair so my background is human
resources I've been doing human
resources for way longer than I would
like to admit um and nine years of it
has been in healthcare so I have uh
industry
experience the the there are um
expectations that employers do
background checks but however there's no
um consistent set criteria for each
institution so what one institution
might feel um is not eligible for
employment another one might say that
there is and so it really is either
internal employer policy or just they
need B so they're more lenient but the
Board of Nursing has strict criteria
what is acceptable and what isn't
acceptable and those that have um
questional backgrounds um they're
required to submit an explanation in
front of the board and then if the board
wants additional information we ask them
to come before us in a show cause
hearing so we can have a dialogue with
them to understand what occurred and and
make determinations on um whether or not
um we would issue a license or not based
on uh those criteria okay and thank you
and that follow up Mr chair yeah that
would become an after Thea process then
if this happens there if there's no
background check up
front and and maybe I I I'd be
interested to hear what anyone else has
to say whether they think that's
necessary can you be a carpenter for
example if if you're back whatever
whatever we don't Li whatever industry
you want to be in can you can you do
that industry if you have had
XYZ problems with the criminal justice
system and so are we saying if you have
been found guilty of elder abuse can you
be an
LNA right now no but um without a
background check you possibly could so
for for example yesterday one of the
background checks was sexual um sexual
assault of a minor that came before us
so that we have simple assault we've had
kidnapping we've had drug um um drug
possession but yesterday if we didn't do
a background check that individual who
um was arrested for sexual assault of a
minor could work and we would not know
that right and so there there really
needs to be um some precautions and and
guard rails surrounding background
checks for the employers you know for
the the people that are looking for
licenses know you put somebody in a
long-term care facility that's that's an
issue and and I think this was said
excuse me I'm sorry I think this was
said yes the in the testimony the first
day that once something has happened
it's too late to fix it and so maybe we
need to have this background so just
just to get a feel on this um yeah sorry
the elder abuse is obvious but what sort
of uh things uh you know the people
might have u a background issue that
would be considered acceptable for I
mean with simple like cannabis
possession or something right something
like that yes um you know it would if if
somebody had criteria on DUI for example
right or was it were they there's a
difference between having a DUI versus
being impaired at work you know was were
they um was it drug possession was it
impairment at work or was it I was young
and dumb and did something that I
shouldn't have and I've learned my
lesson because it happened 10 years ago
but those are are all things that come
before us that we question and look at
and review which has that the parameters
for safety so I I'd like to if people
are okay with it cut this short and okay
representative G thank you Mr chair my
question to you all is with a
license is a licens nurses aid able to
advertise and accept employment
privately in homes with patients in New
Hampshire is there anything in the law
preventing someone once they issued a
license from hanging out a shingle and
taking
employment no they could do that but if
they're and they do do if they go
through so in that
scenario um an individual hiring an LNA
that would not most likely not do a
background check correct but we would
have that safety guard in the front end
when they were obtaining a license to be
able to clear them to work as an LNA you
have that now but if this goes through
the way we're saying it would not be
there and that's what this committee is
not hearing is that it's not all nice
little agencies that we can hope are
going to have the kind of criteria that
will protect the elderly from theft from
their drugs being stolen and sold on the
street like oxyen and the other highly
addictive drugs from their money being
taken from the other kinds of abuses
that happen from child molesters going
into the home because the public thinks
oh the state's giving a license this
person must be safe they're licensed
correct I'd like I see where this is
going I thank
you okay the nursing board do they still
have the criminal background check is
one with you know neglect and abuse
reported ba the
yeah the Bureau of BU of elderly and
Affairs uh registry yes do they still
have that how is
nursing I might actually be able to
answer that because I used to be elderly
and Adult Services general counsel at
HHS and I actually did registry hearings
um so if you act if you look at in the
CFR
48316 part of the registry content is
that um the as part of the registry the
state must provide any response to an
inquiry that includes a finding of abuse
neglect or misappropriation of property
uh also included a statement disputing
the finding and then it um Down Below in
the CFR adds some more detail uh
documentation of the state's
investigation nature of the
allegation date of the hearing statement
by the individual um section D is
important the information must be
included in the registry within 10
working days of the findings and must
remain in the registry permanently but
what that means is when you're
practicing somebody does something you
have a hearing over at the aaou at HHS
and uh the administrative you know they
find find against you your name goes on
that list for for those purposes um I
can also say that I don't think there's
a requirement for facilities to check
that registry Beyond initial
hiring and just as a followup um
currently we do not run a beas or DCF
registry check when someone is applying
for a license here in New Hampshire so
we only do the FBI fingerprinting which
only comes back if there is um law
enforcement
involvement just to clar so you don't
cross check with criminal background
check to B we do not have that requ that
there is no requirement for that okay so
there used to be a thing in old models
where doctor go bad and he get struck
off the registry is that's what's going
to happen here that these people are
registered but they've abuse the elderly
and they get struck off well that's what
Jackie wants to work out yeah I I would
like to please uh I would I would like
to make a motion that we um eliminate we
we get rid of section one and any SE any
parts of section 10 that uh Mr oser
House assures me only is related to the
removal of the LNA license which I think
is most of the 326b stuff but not all of
it um and then what I would do is
include that as part of the amendment I
get OS to put together and would send
out to people and what we're voting on
here is this is our
intent and um and then you know we'll
either have an opportunity as the
subcommittee or the full committee to
vote on the final Amendment if people
are okay with any discussion I said
second that motion my only concern is
that background check not attached to
the LNA that's a critical link Missing
Link I understand that's I mean it
sounded to me like we were okay I mean
people could maybe get comfortable with
all of it because they could add the
training requirement because but because
of the way the federal thing works we
can't add the background check and so
there's a larger effort going on in the
nursing thing and maybe there's a way to
fix it there I don't know Jackie can
look at Jackie can look at it and um and
I you know whatever my view is on this
um you know I don't think we're we're
not going to get through this with the
background check uh requirement removed
no you're not okay so that would be my
hesitation big hesit understand some of
what you said earlier I didn't hear
because it was going that way about
representative gr's what she's doing
representative groda she spoke to me
later yesterday I think
and um so I don't know the details but
there is a bill is it um if if anyone's
familiar with it is it just a study or
is it actually going to do something I
don't know but there is another bill
related to nursing and which she said is
you know if we
remove this part out of this bill the
LNA part out of this bill that you know
she would add it and address it as part
of the larger Bill and that's what I'm
proposing I mean so she's proposing a
whole uh for and nursing as a
entirety that's that's my understanding
from what she said and so um I don't
think we you know there's going to be
disagreement on this one for you know
reasonable reasons um and so my proposal
my Mo motion which is who second you did
okay um
eliminate yeah yeah section
one that's a huge T no no uh it's uh no
no no no it's short it's short no let me
let me get to it it's it's um right page
no it's no it doesn't go to page three
because that's well it's only page it's
it which we had uh which we'll get to in
a in a bit okay um and anything any
parts of section 10 and I don't know if
you have those
or what I don't have the specific
language in front of me okay so I we
could take a look at the list can you
get back to me
when yeah all right all right so I was
kind of hoping to put an amendment in
well we're not going to when when are we
executing we're not executing
until
February I I don't know that we have to
meet again but if we have to we can just
meet before but the question is when do
we need this for Carol and I think we're
wait when did she say we were going to
be executing after session on which
day the first
okay we have is it next Thursday yeah
we're gonna be going on for a while here
I mean end sometime on
Monday sometime on Monday okay thank you
and and so it's the motion is to repeal
page one lines one to five just to be
clear you want me to go through this
list see strike the ones that that are
related to to the LNA lure okay and and
just just give me a list you know of
which ones because I have to give it to
all us to and and more discussion uh
line P I mean sorry so the section
10 I have to write this up 10 for um you
repeals we there's no guarantees in life
but I I think I think you know she said
she would I she's been trustworthy um
not but I mean she and she may not get
it in I mean she can try and do
something who knows what will happen and
it may not be something we like but what
I think the situation right now is
there's concern about this background
check right show you know even if some
of us you know voted to pass this as is
trusting the employer except There's
issues you know it's I don't see it
passing the committee and so I don't see
any point in you know in holding this
bill up the parts we want to get through
because of this section that's my my
biggest concern or question for that is
the fact that the highest need is for
elderly LNA for elderly services and the
most vulnerable population and we also
want the workforce to stay stable and
will this effect if I ask you will this
jeopardize what we are embarking on by
making
it less safe or I I don't want to use
the word less safe but less oversight
will it improve Workforce or will it
reduce the qu are you asking about how
the bill is written or at the motion
that representative leus has made at the
motion to remove Elan out of it his
motion I believe was to repeal the
removal is that correct right that would
leave things as they are today unchanged
so I think his motion was to leave the
statute as it is not as it is proposed
here right so there would be I mean the
the and you can speak to this my
understanding is one of the reasons for
this is you know lnas don't get paid a
whole lot we actually want to get people
in the field they and U and had
requiring both the registration which we
must and the license which we could get
rid of um you know sets up more hurdles
and more cost and more time and so the
goal here I think was to help get more
lnas and so by removing the section
we're not helping with that goal but
there are con concerns and I mean that's
why I mean that's why I support it in
the first place but but one one last
quick question sorry yeah keep we both
keep turning it on I'll let you thank
you uh Mr chairman I just wanted to say
and um that's why I have confidence this
will get picked up in another one
because the bottom line is we want our
lowest income employees which
are uh in the field our our licensed
nursing aids to not be hit with these
fees we want to protect them from the
punitive damage that our duplica current
duplicative process has on them while
still recognizing the safety for the our
most vulnerable the elderly and we know
we that's a large part of our population
understand and I don't I don't know you
know the answer to that but hopefully it
can be fine the other thing I would
recommend to um res M you it seem to
have some concerns that the current
process which would stay um doesn't have
this Che back or there's some elderly
abuse thing what I would say is talk to
uh representative groa and maybe as part
of her process something could happen
and with this changes will the
um opportunity for the lna's growth in
the career path does that make it uh
more easy to move on to licensed nursing
or next level kind of thing the
opportunity for career growth
I don't think that this changes any of
those requirements or would I'm not sure
how that would affect
that that would
be yes representative Browns all right
thank you Mr chair take and thank you
folks at the table again so if we
eliminate section
one does that make page three line 24
through
point I think already asked that I think
the answer was no but he can see what he
says that's kind of the question I
already asked but do you still we still
have to maintain the registry okay thank
you that's simple thank you and then um
okay um any other discussion on this or
um all in
favor anybody opposed okay so that's
that's what we'll do um and when I get
the details from Mr aerous I will draft
that part of the amendment so let's go
back Mr chair can I ask one quick follow
up to the something that came out in
that previous discussion um as we're
talking about possible amendments so I'm
very concerned to hear that um the
dcyf uh registry and the other registry
are not being checked for licensing
currently and is that something that can
be done in rulemaking or do you need
something legislatively should we add
something in this bill as it if we are
doing an amendment
that that directs you to look at those
two Registries uh I mean why are we
keeping safety Registries of known
problems against women and children and
the elderly and not looking at it when
we're issuing license I think that's
probably a question better posed to HHS
than us um I don't know much about oplc
uh but the comment I made was a few
years back maybe three years ago now
when I was beas counsel there was a
requirement to check the registry upon
hiring but not after after that so if an
individual is subsequently added an
employer might not know I they send
notifications HHS would highly recommend
employers check frequently some do not
all and I would just I just want to add
in um other experiences I would say um
like uh Mr asera just said that oh has
to correct me every time I'm sorry um
that it you would want to look first at
HH
because they have specific rules and
regulations on who they can release it
to so if the change was going to come
from somewhere I think that would have
to be step one and then looking at oplc
rules and regulations would be step
two and as I said I'd suggest taking
that up with Jackie because they're
doing a larger study on nursing and that
could be something that they could deal
with there that's my suggestion not not
trying to do here we don't know yeah as
of now I think the agencies whether it's
small agency or big big large hospital
it you know you're supposed to uh report
to bees and uh it's the
individuals where they don't have access
they trust you to say you have the
license you know and that is the one
that would be they'll fall through the
cracks and that would be the concern
because if you have to get licensed
agency certified to practice that or
provide that Services you have to to do
these things correct that's on the
employers own you're right and there's a
growing I mean I know a lot of people
hiring private licensed nursing aids for
their parents and
grandparents so I'd like to go back then
to section 4 which starts on page three
line 21 and ends on page 4 line 28 which
we had started on and there's really
only two changes in there one is the
addition at the end of that starting at
line 24 on page P well it start the
whole section starts on page three line
21 and the whole thing ends on page four
line
28 and so there's two changes in here
the rest of its existing statute one is
starting on page four line 24 till the
end is what we just discussed which is
you know uh having them handle the
registry which is they're required to do
um the only other changes understand it
is on page three line
25 which is another one of these things
where under the changes we made last
year we moved certain Authority from the
board to oplc and this change just says
this has to be done said in set of by
the board under this chapter and
elsewhere under this chapter tells oplc
to do it so it's it's kind of a clean up
right those two changes and so may I ask
a clarifying question Mr chair so my
understanding is that line 24 through 28
on page four is simply putting into
statute practice that's already
happening thank you right and so I guess
why do it need to be there I just it's a
good idea clarification okay all right
thank you how does the Board of Nursing
or
nurse yeah actually good point do you
folks or anybody have uh any issue with
this SE that should clarify or that's
clean no we're we're fine with that the
biggest concern was the background
checks for us
yeah
understand certainly I'd like to move
that we uh to agreement on section four
four we keep it as is and keep it
as
you okay any um all in favor I anyone
good all right another one down moving
along moving yeah I mean you think this
is bad Jackie with that sick how many
655 which was two 300 Pages was just
ridiculous and it was done the same we
actually broke that bill up and had
separate subcomittee
meetings Okay
um well I'd like to do section
five
[Music]
um yeah apparently so this is short this
runs from page four line 29 through line
[Music]
and and so what was
it and this moves the requirement to
arrange for the background check from
the board to the office that's where it
STS out board and ads office and if I
could ask it lists inste instead of just
saying initial licensure it adds the as
a licensed practical nurse registered
nurse advanced practice Nur nurse is
that just to make it clear or is there I
think it was to specify that the LNA
wouldn't need to do it so if you're not
going to move forward with the repeal of
the LNA piece we can probably take this
s and just leave the rest strike a board
and ADD office I think so
okay Mr chair can I ask for so only for
LNA that they have to do their own
background check how about the nurses
and I think there's a m i mean you
correct me but well go on you can answer
if we remove that sentence everyone will
have to do the background check so I
think the idea that Chang is originally
it was everybody had to do it but if we
were going to take out lnas and because
they couldn't do a background check for
lnas to take them out they then had to
list who needed them if that's
correct uh uh sir Brown thank you thank
you Mr chair so yes so if we eliminate
the Bold part on 31 and 32 then we do
have a background check for the nursing
assistant LNA leaves it in it would be
everyone licensed by which solves what
we've been talking about thank you let
me ask this question if it is if can't
we make a rule to say only L's
background check will be paid not by the
LNA because they're the lowest paid uh
that would be done automatically when
they do the licensing that's that's well
is it paid by the LNA now or or that
that is the big contest right but the
the issue is if you do that it could be
done and again I'd suggest dealing with
the the larger thing Jack represent grow
is but there's a law that says the
license the boards they have to be
self-funding and so if you're going to
have them pay for the background check
they're going to have to add it to the
licensing fees for the lnas under
current statute oh that's a registra
yeah that it's just mood point but if
the main reason we are trying to cut the
cost for them right that is if there's a
way
of voucher give something just for the
but then you'd have to specify where the
money comes from are you going to have
licenses for other professions subsidize
it do it come from the general
fund yeah right I mean so that's a
larger question and again i' either take
it as a separate bill or part of
Representative grotus thing okay yeah
certainly
oh go on I
was okay that's
fine okay I will here's my question
if is there any harm in leaving this in
the way it is the bolded section yeah
because it it will no longer require
that the lnas have a background check
which I thought people were concerned
about for initial licensure as a
licensed practical because lnas aren't
in that list shall submit to the board a
criminal history record release form but
lnas aren't in the list oh so we would
have to add the LNA back in here so
here's my concern if Jackie works out
some different
language is there a way we can write
this that isn't harmful but will cover
us if Jackie works out another way to
eliminate the duplicate of license yeah
Jack I mean in another bill you can make
that we don't have we don't have to do
anything here I know we don't have to
but what I'm saying is we can save
ourselves a lot of trouble if we add
licensed nurse in here I would actually
say it would save us trouble and Jackie
not to do that the only reason is if
let's say they
decide you know what represent M py
wanted so they're going to they're going
to say we're going to pay for the lna's
background checks from something the
general fund or whever right then all
they would have to do as part of that
bill is uh is add this line okay back
you know they can add it in and we're
not going to add it in so we're going to
leave it they could just change the
statute as this would but we're not all
right you're going to have conflicting
changes I hear you so we're taking that
out instead of this laundry list said LI
or registration well that's actually
another well because under 541a they
consider under 541a they consider
yeah just just for a curios how many l
do we have in the state approximately
about
20,000 huh what I we have 12,000 lnas
and um of the 12,000 there's
approximately 1,000 that are m&as but
under our board we have just shy of
total yeah so there's 12,000 total
lnas and of the 12,000 1,000 of them are
lnas and
m&as okay um representative
motion yeah what it would be would be to
to take to right to to remove the Bold
in those two lines second I I would make
32 that's P yeah page four yeah make a
motion am I do what sorry I just want to
take some notes line 31 to 32 to and
your motion is motion is that we
amend page four line 31 and 32 removing
the
Bold type which is added information
leaving it as it was in RSA 321 326
b151 okay accepting the changes of board
to office board to office right right
Excuse me yes but not including the
change of board to office on line 32 or
line 34 want those I mean don't remove
those yes not including okay yeah all
right yeah second second all right I'm
confused sorry all right so let me see
if I can clarify and then anybody else
can so what what he's saying is that we
would take section one we would just
remove the part that's in bold on lines
31 and 32 and do nothing
else so every
right
yes yeah and if I may that's what that
ver so license
so okay so the responsibility
onc to make sure they get the back yeah
as it is as it is today right it doesn't
change it
so uh all all uh we have representative
G second it so um all in favor uh anyone
opposed I don't hear anything another
unanimous
article um all right so that was five
what else have we
got
certainly what do the background check
cost
just about $25 okay thank you oh it's
still 25 this is 12 years AG 8 25 sorry
what 4825 4825 yeah I was thinking it
was 12 years ago 15 years ago 25 $482
$48.25 we we got a precise out oh we
have the the real
EST um I apologize that's because we do
a state only which is 25 and then the
federal background check which is the
additional fee so it's a total of
4825 nothing I didn't think I fully made
that
um okay so what I'd suggest doing now is
can I can I interrupt real quick
absolutely uh page four line 37 we
changed lure to registration but if it's
going to stay lure we could probably not
do that change as
well
oh ah is that the only thing in section
six no there's a bunch of I haven't
turned the page yet we'll have to we'll
deal with Section six and okay we can do
that there but thank you oh I didn't I
thought you were flipping Pages sorry no
thank you for for pointing that out um
that's why you're here and I'd like
clarification on the whole registration
versus license is it currently a dual
licensing procedure that's happening as
soon as the LNA passes their
certification they're put on the
registry but they can't practice in the
state until they get that Ling second
level of licing
so yes so currently it really is a
registration and a license yes the
onlyc yeah registration occurs when
you're put in the registry I
guess all right um so this one the next
what I'd like to do is something
different and that is section two which
is dealing with the um among other
things the membership of the Board of
Nursing can I make a quick statement
about this absolutely the language here
was actually already approved
by House and Senate Edna last year but
because there were so many bills uh
floating around hb2 655 409 at one point
after this was approved another bill
retroactively changed it back to what it
was oh I remember that so I think I
think it was SP 107 that may or may not
have been my fault uh which is why I'm
aware of it but I I want to point out
that this has already been approved by
thank you for that but given that we're
not bound by what we we ourselves did
last year it might be helpful I I
appreciate that that's good
information um so first of all does
anyone I'm going to ask people you know
to see who have an opinion on or any
issue with this I'm okay with it and we
actually voted for it last year which
page oh I'm sorry uh page one starting
at
line seven no six uh six actually page
22 and we can go through what it does U
maybe there's somebody here from if
you'd like
to um again Samantha O'Neal chair of the
board um we have the board has a concern
about decreasing the number of um board
members um and in March of 2023 three uh
we were actually approved to increase
our board numbers uh from 11 to
13 um we have I have been on the board
since September 2017 and during my
tenure on the board we have not had any
issues with the Quorum whether it be our
monthly meetings if we have a special
meeting or if we have emergency hearings
our board is um obviously voluntary and
very committed to their service they
come prepared uh we don't have an issue
at all with the Quorum um but in
addition to that each of our board
members have a have a specialty and so
that is very important when we're
looking at best practice um clinical
practice you know we have myself as
human resources we have someone we have
multiple people who are hospital setting
APRN Home Care uh long-term care
facility uh ambulatory and each one one
um brings a level of expertise that not
the other one has so you can tap into
that individual's expertise and
knowledge to be able to make sound
decisions when we're addressing lenses
and what their particular matter is
that's before us um and if we change
that you know it's different saying I'm
going to fire you because you're not
doing a good job that's much different
then we're going to suspend or put your
license on probation or revoke a license
because you've done something without
having that level of expertise from our
various board members okay could someone
from oplc if they want director Courtney
or someone else who would comment on
this and somebody will have to give her
some room she can kick somebody out
bad she's the boss so the only positive
thing is I get to say where I want
um thank you lindsy Courtney executive
director oplc I would I mean I would
agree with chair O'Neal's uh
observations I think that we certainly
have boards that have Quorum issues and
or issues with engagement in the sense
that you know they're not reviewing the
materials and they're not actively
participating they're playing Candy
Crush while they no joke um while while
there's a hearing um that is not an
issue for the Board of Nursing at all um
I would say that they uh their packets
are more jam-packed than any other board
you know if you print it out it's like
this um over a thousand Pages they have
more hearings than anybody else they
take it very
seriously um and so from that standpoint
we don't have any concerns at the office
about their ability to get business done
okay Mr chair sir question if I could
just get some a little something here
first uh for understanding and um so in
uh Roman one of this that's just that's
changing the
membership well also there's and taking
out the line any interested individual
whatever is that just because that isn't
necessary or what's the deal with that
section being removed line on lines nine
and
10 so I think that language I mean is
not necessary yeah because anybody can
make any recommendation to the governor
and ultimately it's up to him so I think
that's probably why that was removed
okay it just complicates things for no
good reason that was kind of my take on
it all right and so but otherwise what
this
is yeah yeah well and also who the
members are so if we if we got rid of
this it would go to the current thing
which is 13 members appointed correct
and right now it's uh six registered
nurses uh two now you're taking out of
whom Shelby is that just redundant
language So currently aprns have to
maintain lure as an RN as well so this
says currently in law you have to have
six RNs two of whom shall be
aprns okay so why would but but why was
the of whom shall be I mean that
otherwise that Clause isn't changed
that's all that's taken out I mean maybe
it isn't necessary but that's weird well
I I think it no no well I think it just
makes clear that you've got a certain
number of aprns certain number of RNs
okay um I just trying to clean up the
language just clean it up so I mean
having even it sounds to me like these
two things I just talked about leaving
those deletions in there even if we
leave everything else the same makes
sense well I think if you wanted to
clean up the language and maintain the
existing composition of the bo you could
just say the members of the board shall
include four aprns two a you know two
aprns two two LPN three l or we could
just get or you could just get rid of
this whole section correct which would
be simpler which I'm a big fan of but um
oh the other one
is uh
L oh I see that's just because you went
from plural to singular on line 12 I'm
just looking at what I'm looking to see
and okay and I mean I get to people's
questions on the committee but but just
quickly is there anybody here who has an
objection to leaving the this um makeup
of the board the same as it is now and
part okay um and questions on the sub my
only question U Mr chair is are you
saying was had one pending oh so she
still has it with your board board
members do you use both hybrid if in
case they can do Zoom versus all in
person that flexibility might give a lot
more compliance for core correct do you
use
hybrid okay yes I would say this board
does not have a problem though meeting
Quorum under any circumstance I think
that they try to attend in person
because it's more you know it's easier
but um but yeah absolutely they they
have some members that attend remotely
for various issues as authorized it it's
just to make sure that if I'm an RN and
I'm on you know don't get out on time at
3 but there is a board meeting at least
I can call in and be participatory yes
then driving up for an hour certainly
although their meetings last all day so
they they
typically um have the day you know they
take the day but absolutely absolutely
did I miss anything representative
G thank you Mr chair um I I just wanted
a clarification of what you were saying
in terms
of get rid of the section are you saying
we're going to get rid of the whole
section no no no I I mean removing it
from the amendment and well actually
we'd have we wouldn't really do that
sorry because this is to make it read as
this so we would we would make it go
back to what's in statute so so from
line six through well eight eight
actually well eight seven eight or no it
starts at well eight actually or six yes
six through 15 through 15 we would
just do away with the cross outs and do
away with the Bold additions all the
changes and so it goes back to the the
current text of the statute that's what
I'm intending so but I if I heard it
correctly the board wanted to go from
Seven member to 13 but but in current
statute it's 13 the amendment was to
drop it to seven oh okay okay got it I
guess the only other question director
Courtney is you know what was the
original impetus for this section so I
think if you recall back in
hb2 um the original
version um last year the governor had
proposed completely reducing the size of
pretty much every board to five or seven
and the impetus was really just
generally there's a um challenge with
recruiting and retaining public
members so by reducing the size you
reduce the number to one public member
again that hasn't been an issue for this
specific board but um but I think that
was the general just okay so it was a
broad brush and correct right and and if
you look in uh the calendar that house
calendar just came out there's a member
notice in there that's going to point
hopefully Point people at you thank you
we finally got in I appreciate it we'll
see if it works um um any other
questions uh so uh for you yes so
process-wise we would just remove this
entire section well the changes to it be
but because on line seven or Line 6 it
says amend RSA 32 326 B3 to read as
follows if we actually remove the
section that means we would delete it
from statute which is not what we want
to do because then there'd be no members
on the board as the the newest and most
naive member of this committee I I would
say that doesn't look like the case but
well actually it's kind of the the way
okay to read these things what happens
is we're telling we're telling whoever
modifies the statutes is take 326 B3 and
rip it out and replace it with what we
provide here and if what we provide here
doesn't have section one there will be
no members on the board and I don't
think that'll work well no if
we if we remove the ENT entire section
no one even considers a change to the
RSA right no wrong okay thank you no
we're actually telling them remove all
of the current RSA section and replace
it with what's in the bill understood
okay so basically saying no board don't
no members no appointment that's would
not work so may I just ask clarification
yeah I think I could be wrong but I
think if you just delete the entire
section um regarding nursing assistant
we would just stay the course under
existing statute and if the committee
wanted to make changes to
326b obviously that's when you would um
well there's other changes Down Below in
other sections which we're going to talk
about we haven't talked about yet so
that's I mean you know excellent if we
wanted to get rid of all of section two
that'd be fine and if it turns out in
discussion we decide to get rid of all
the changes there then fine then we'll
get rid of the whole section you just
kill a bill okay but I'm I'm I I'm not
anticipating we'll do that understood
thank you for that clarification
represent and so what I'd like to do is
um because there's pieces here that have
different effects and meanings not just
on the me you know I would like to just
take a very quick vote are people fine
with leaving the membership of the board
as specified in section one uh Roman one
of section two alone the way it is in
statute today so that's my motion what
you're basically saying is
nothing is going to be struck correct
all the
struck no added no nothing okay so it'll
all come back up all right so okay um so
let me let me record this or at the end
of the day I will never remember what we
did and I will never be go back to what
it was without the strike stay the same
correct um actually not not remove but
revert basically all right all right um
all in favor
anyone opposed no good all right
is I think I had myself I did it and and
representative Brown we're all set okay
so section two it looks like all it's
doing is where it specifies RN it's
going to allow an APRN is
that um so be and it's the rest is the
same is that my understanding corre
correct that's Roman two of section two
uh line 16 through 20 of page one oh oh
correct I think it just makes clear what
the requirements are for to be an APRN
member of the board does anybody here
have an objection to that change I mean
anyone Okay cool so uh yeah I think we
may combine other things but we will
remember we agreed to that um and then
section
two uh
four three oh oh actually we do need to
make some changes yeah they're they're
changing the T well they're singular to
plural because of the proposed right
they're reflecting different number okay
but that's not the case
for for three yeah
and um and then
four uh actually it's got it goes from
members to member which is a problem
residents to Res that's a a resident so
from mple to single but what it's also
doing is it's striking these members
shall have a minimum of five years
experiences in LNA at least three of
which shall have immediately preceded
the date of their appointment I see
that's being removed and that's and
what's I can guess but what's the the
reason for
that I would just guess and so I don't
want to guess um I think it would be to
open up membership I would say though
that I think and I can't speak for the
board I think the board has a concern
about that I think for my own
observation
um I I I think it's important to keep
that restriction in many lnas um become
lnas and stay Lenas for a very limited
period of time just for various reasons
and I think uh to to really be able to
offer experience um that you need on a
regulatory board you need some
experience can we can we get a comment
that um we agree that we we would like
to leave that requirement in there for
the reasons that director Courtney
stated um and we have actually with me
today is one of our LNA board members
who her career is LNA um if you want to
hear directly from her as to why she
feels that's important I don't need to
but someone else might but so is there
anybody here who um who wants to remove
this requirement uh I would out here
first just and then we'll talk about it
I just want to get testimony from people
if sounds like nobody so from the
subcommittee represent what I'm thinking
is if I understood the process for LNA
somebody could be on the registry never
worked as LNA didn't get license didn't
have experience but because they are LNA
they can be on the board so their input
would not be as valuable relevant not
Val relevant to practicing elen yes
correct correct yes and that's a very
good point thank you okay thank you yeah
my my guess which apparently is wrong is
that uh lnas wouldn't stay as lnas for
long that they would advance but if
there are people who are making LNA as
their career then yeah that makes sense
thank you uh anyone else because uh well
what I would propose and and we'll group
them together as far as voting is to
actually um leave leave U Roman 4 alone
to not to remove all the changes and
that would uh because we're leaving the
members of the board alone it would
leave the the tense you know the uh the
singular plural thing go back to what
it's in statute and we would leave this
and U yeah it's all the
same
right right so three four and five I'm
looking at five
and yeah a
[Music]
five so
um representative
Brown the to basically leave three four
and five alone is that that okay I
revert
um page one lines
21 through page two
line
three um and that was
brown and
Gould and uh anyone all in
favor anyone opposed no okay
cool all right so we got
that and then
um and then we've
got um on page two starting at line four
Roman
6 no more than two board members should
be associated with any particular
agency anyone here opposed to
this any question I that seems
reasonable to me sorry oh No actually
that's not a change I apologize so
actually the rest down to line 13 where
things are struck out it's unchanged
okay that's fine thank
you um
so if you could if someone director
Courtney what is the deal with striking
out uh Roman 91 and
11 last year in s SP 107 we drafted
language that was applicable to all the
boards so this is basically redundant
language now okay okay
um quick question last year's uh leg
last
legislative has it made it to the ru
making yet or it's in the process it's
in the
statute so there's no Ru making
so would you like motion yeah and and
give me a moment to to write some things
down um what I the motion I'd like is um
otherwise I have the two things about
reverting those
um two sections and I would say
otherwise um
[Music]
leave um section
two
uh as
is if somebody can make that motion that
was uh M py or somebody want to Second
right okay all in
favor oh
certainly so we're talking
about
except for what we just discussed around
section one and sections three four and
gonna a microphone please thank sorry
that we're keep my notes say that we're
we're keeping the
same line six through 18 we're going to
leave what's in the bill the same yep or
let's let's try to get the same
terminology so we're say we're saying
the same thing deleting from the bill
and deleting from statute so let me go
through and see and I'll go through it
and make sure with what I'm saying yeah
um that
um that Roman one uh we're going to
revert to current statute which is 13
members y right all those changes go
away correct and the same thing is the
case for Roman Roman 2 will leave us is
in the bill Roman Roman Ro Roman two
what again would stay as it's in the
bill correct keep the change and all
we're doing is we're saying treating
APRN is equivalent to right right no I'm
good okay so that'll stay as in the bill
yep sections 3 four
five
um right and actually with throwing up
the changes four 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and 11
will all remain as in the bill correct
no changes Oh No actually that's not
true I apologize because I miss I missed
three four and five will revert to
current statute correct and 6 7 8 9 10
and 11 will revert to current to will
stay as in the bill yeah yeah yeah that
works 9 11 that works and we want we
want to keep striking the that's yeah so
as I understand it that's the
motion thank you thank you Mr chair well
the the bill would strike them from
current
statute already done previous Bill had
done done it's
just um no it didn't do it in correct me
if I'm wrong it didn't strike it in from
this part of the RSA it it added it to a
higher level that applied to
everything correct it's it's it's in our
our a 310 yeah which is the overall
oplc correct correct I mean you don't
need to but to make it nice and neat for
us you end up with nightmares like if
some future legislature changes the one
in 310 then this will stay in here and
there'll be generate a conflict which is
Ood that was my mistake Mr sorry okay so
um if we
understand if we understand what we're
voting on uh all in favor I all all
opposed none all right all right thank
you um so I think that finishes section
two um
so we're done with one
two we're done with
three we're we're done with uh I'm sure
we're done four but let me
go let me let me take a look back we did
four we did four we
did five
we were going to get into six so we're
six and maybe future such bills could be
SE I don't know it's actually more work
if they're separate bills I guess but
okay so what is this doing this I'm
sorry uh we're starting at page four
line
35 and
continuing where does seven star starts
at line 36 page 5 um okay oh yeah I'm
missing it because it's right at the
bottom of the page all right
um
so if I mean okay I know
uh attorney mister I don't know what's
appropriate but ostra house hey you Doug
no we've been dealing a lot together I
don't want to be
disrespectful but um so
so you mentioned that um there's an
issue something needs to change here
because we kept the um the L stuff
correct because you didn't do away with
the LNA is that only line 37 well I
haven't turned the page yet okay you're
page it's not that late we shouldn't be
getting silly and that's me that's on me
um yeah if I might yeah it looks like
line the deletion on line seven and8
will have to remain
um because they still can't apply for
[Music]
license right so
we so what is this doing so the first um
let's go through this so the first part
is on line 37 on page four is just there
be because of section one right director
Courtney actually has a recommendation
that most of these changes were just to
Common compliance with cfrs but we can
probably do away with all of section six
um yeah we just right whole section out
of the
bill and so other so there's two things
there's the dealing with the fact that
the elenas were going to go away the
license we're going to keep lnas um and
and to become in compliance with cfrs
but do we need the language to come in
compliance with
cfrs no so the New Hampshire um this
statute was very artfully crafted as is
what artfully crafted to be in
compliance with the Federal cfrs in the
sense that in order to be on the
registry you have to have quote taken a
state approved Nursing Registry
assistant program so during the state of
emergency and then thereafter um this
language basically States you shall be
deemed to have taken a program if you
you know if you have certain um a
certain mos in in in the military
service so I don't think we should mess
too much with it it the the changes are
intended to allow somebody on the
registry to if you were doing away with
ler to also continue to satisfy and be
placed on the registry but if you're no
longer making that change you don't need
any of these changes that are in section
six okay um I just wouldn't want to mess
with the Lure by alternate experience
right um so I'm going to make a motion
then we'll have discussion and my motion
is that we remove section six from the
bill and now we can have in a second a
second remove by removing it from the
bill then you remove the changes I know
the language is funny
it's well see because what it does is it
says nurse
practice it says there's a SE if you
take out section
six
representative ghoul if you take out
section six you're also you're taking
out the part that says amend RSA 326b
21-a to read is following if you take
that out you're not making any changes
to RSA 321 I understand that um Mr chair
with all due respect but as you see in
other places the the the current statute
gets printed out and it's just the
changes that wouldn't be in here we
wouldn't be removing the section of the
chapter from the amendment we would be
removing the section from the bill we
would not be removing it from statute
right um all right so so you did
somebody yeah you made the motion I made
the okay so me uh and then we can have
discussion if there's um just need to
write
down okay and discussion representative
MTI question since we have an LNA I
would like to ask if they having licens
make them feel more professional or not
having license just a simple question
sure I know direct care professional got
yes my name is Melissa tle an L um for
me and my more seasoned elas the license
is very important to us um I know
there's issues with cost and I know a
lot of us would be willing to cover that
cost to keep that license because I know
it's a play of words but for us it's our
career thank you that that was my and
just uh you know just a a a follow up on
on that so as I understand it the title
would still be licensed nursing
assistant even if if that part went away
I so I'm a little wondering why what's
and and also at least what we proposed
doing until we ran into the background
check issue was that the the training
requirement would be the same everything
else would be the same you'd still be
called in LNA under the law it'd be
considered a
license um and you just wouldn't have to
go through the double process
I yeah and it's all on player words and
everybody it's means something different
to the way you word it for us being
licensed you go and you see a license
number on a registry you're no longer
you're just a person just a name there's
nothing attached to it so when we search
other CNAs in other states it's just a
name but when you go on your license you
can see your whole history your whole
record how long you've been there that
goes away when you're on a registry
because it's just updated every two
years okay thanks for helping me
understand because I didn't I didn't
really get it yeah uh representative
Brown so um thank you Mr chair
yeah clarify for me when when you if
you're on the registry you must get a
document from oplc that says you are
this and is there a number
there so I I think the way the state has
implemented the registry and The Lure
they they historically have complet the
two and because lure has been required
there hasn't been a separate
notification that goes out regarding
registration but we use the same
licensing system and if you pull up
somebody's name who is an LNA there will
be two entries one it'll say registry
only and it'll have a number the other
will be licensed nursing assistant and
it would have a number I think if we
were to operationalize the bill as
proposed you would just eliminate the
registry portion because you would be
required to refer to lnas as
lnas um that's how we would
operationalize it but in practice they
do not receive a document right now that
says you're on the registry we just we
send them the document when they get the
license but I think it honestly we
probably should be sending both but I
think in practice the the the processes
have been conflated MH
any other questions represent Mony yeah
in if you're trying to save cost for the
lnas and we are increasing the cost for
oplc if you have to send two cards to
think right or is it like Driver's
License non- Driving ID non driver's ID
so the cost there's really not an
additional cost the the issue with the
cost is that um to be on the registry
we're not permitted to charge anyone to
be on the registry because the state is
getting funds for the registry now the
issue is those funds are not going to
the office they're going to the
Department of Health and Human Services
and we get a very small portion of that
and the reason for that is because we
have this duplicative process I'm not
able to parse out and say these expenses
are due to their registry but these
expenses are due to the L and I think if
you were to basically combine the
process into one process we could say
this entire process is a million dollars
please pay up but right now that's not
that's the issue with the cost I mean we
certainly you know we we have funding um
but that's the issue with the cost it's
an allocation issue Mr chair there's the
answer for the funding yeah just gonna
ask so so if we had kept section one
um and and got rid of the licensing
process just kept with certification
would that funding basically pay for in
effect what you're calling a license for
the
lnas yes the other way to handle this is
to just eliminate the fee but the money
yes and then that the license could be
considered the
registry and then I could go to HHS and
say give me a million dollars but right
now I can't you know I mean the bulk of
the
the board of nursing a lot of their
hearings have to do with lnas but I
can't say that you know the cost of
Prosecuting those cases and
investigating those cases is because of
the license versus the registration and
vice versa so that so practically that's
the problem so you're not diluting the
standard you're not demoting or you know
psychologically you're not saying the
Ellen is you're not worthy of Licensing
license it's called I mean that be I
mean if it weren't for the concerns
about the background check issue I would
really push to keep section one because
it would it would it eliminate the cost
to become an LNA they're called license
it's going to show up on the thing as a
license the whole deal um but I think
what's standing in the way of it right
now is the concern is there's some way
to deal that's what I'm saying for the
funding for background check if you
combine the registry and the license
thing and give it to director courney
can answer me but I don't think the
federal money can be used for background
check because they don't they say you
they I don't know no it can't be used
for the background check um they have to
pay the $48.25 so
um but what's the application fee well
their application fee is $35 but the
average cost the average cost of
lure is
$155 so they the license fee of $35 is
not covering the $155 cost so be because
of overhead and because of staff and
because you know all the other things so
but to be on the registry we can't even
charge them the $35 so you know
if if structurally if it were combined
if the fee were eliminated and we
treated it as one process I could go to
HHS and say pay me 155 per person I
can't do that right now because I can't
attribute certain portion of the
expenditures to the registry versus the
LNA that's the issue with cost so if we
could have kept that F that first part
then uh Not only would you not have to
charge the lnas for the license you
would stop overcharging all the other
nurses to pay for the lna's licenses is
that true more or less yes there you go
yep that that was my point that is that
is probably true I do think there's a
different way to deal with it that's not
statutory which is to just eliminate the
fee because we would be in compliance
with the federal requirements that we
not charge a fee to be on the registry
but um but then could you get get the
money out of I think I
could but you can do that on your own
you don't I yes okay thank you
representative Brown thank you Mr chair
so going back to the the LNA who's who's
here I think it's it it behooves us to
be really fair and considerate of the
feelings of people who have got an LNA
and and they they're proud to have that
title I I I did this I'm an LNA here's
my license and it says that and here's
my
number am I am I 100% clear that if if
this were to move forward as proposed
and and the requirement to go through
the licensing process is removed you're
still going to call them an LNA yeah and
they will receive some type of a
document that says you're an LNA and
here's a number which is going to be
your registration number and would that
be
satisfactory from a making you not feel
bad St standpoint and don't take that
the wrong way I would say the first part
director Courtney can say whether that's
true and then how two questions thank
you there was a followup yeah no that's
fine yes that's true that's how we would
that's how we would do it okay and
then so I think what's really important
at the end of the day for us as lnas
it's just as long as the people that we
work for that we know they're fully
trained competent to do their job we
know background checks have been done
just because of the people I'm in home
care so I'm in people's homes all by
myself I know that I am a good person
but it doesn't mean the person next to
me might be good um so those are our key
important things that are important to
us regardless we know this is where
we're going to go registry license
unlicensed non-licensed we're okay with
that it's just the end result is we're
protected the people are protected
background checks are done and then
that's important to us because a lot of
us don't get into this for the money we
get into it because compassion car we
want to give back we want to help we
want to step in where people
cannot okay thank you thank you I
appreciate that answer thank you so oh
representative gold I just want to say
thank you for what you do yeah
absolutely um so we have the motion to
remove section six from the bill leaving
what's in statute now um do we need any
further
discussion okay um no all right so all
in favor
all opposed I don't hear anyone all
right great um so that's
six we're doing the uh the March through
the bill uh that goes down to
seven
and yeah that's sorry thank you that
starts page five line 36 ends at page
six line four I see only one change
which is another one of the changing
board to office on who issues the
license and all that stuff to accept
that change okay that's let me get to
make some notes here so that's section
[Music]
seven as
is
gold
[Music]
Brown all in favor anyone
excellent okay
um
so Section
8 um I think this is another one just
great section eight as
[Music]
to where's
this of of page I we should probably
look at that once we've gone through the
list in 10 and see if that needs to hang
on a moment
so yeah you got into the next yeah we're
on
eight
oh yeah numbers you got different levels
of numbers and Roman numerals and small
letters and everything else the only
thing I see in eight is on line seven
which says the board to office so so the
nursing board to
oplc that is the only change I see in
this section that's my take so I I would
make a motion that we accept Section 8
as it is
written okay all in favor all opposed
any
opposed okay good so that's
eight and I think we have two more to go
so what is
nine uh oh this is the the teleah health
thing oh and and uh if I could ask
director Courtney or someone um and so
on page six line
18 where it strikes uh 328 I and J is
that related to the LNA removal what is
that about no so if you look in section
10 section 10 proposes to eliminate
registration of medical technicians and
lure of Medical Imaging um so if you do
that then you would need to strike from
our statute their ability to provide
tele Health Services okay I get that um
so I think then the next thing which I I
know there's actually two issues here
there's the which we need to I'd like to
disentangle anyway that's the
registration of medical
technicians which correct me if I'm
wrong
that's um in section 10
lines 22 through 24 is it anything else
is just a radial biology technicians no
well this is there's medical technicians
and then there's the radiation therapy
and Medical Imaging and I'd like to deal
with them separately because at least
I'm thinking we might want to do
different things yes section um lines 22
to 24 are just medical technicians okay
and
10 so so um as and i' I've been involved
in this issue for some years as I just
to get things set up as I understand it
um you know first of all what does
medical technicians cover I'd like you
know what that know what that is um
and what is the reg what's the effect of
the registration other than they
actually just have to there's some list
of their names and presumably address
and whatever is that yes I can cover
that representativ so generally a
medical
technician is anyone who is otherwise
unlicensed who works in a particular
facility who may come into contact with
controlled
drugs that's not an actual profession so
which leads to the um issue that we have
and regardless of what the legislature
does I think there needs to be a change
because we don't have a quorum we have
not had a quorum in years a quorum in um
of a board we don't have a board because
nobody identifies as a medical
technician because it's just somebody
who happens to work in a facility who's
unlicensed who may come into contact
that's not that's not an actual
profession you know it doesn't describe
the activity that they do so we have a
hard time recruiting people so the
registration is very simple do you meet
that criteria you get on the list but
the purpose of the registration
presumably is to protect the public and
so that you're removing people or
disciplining people who do things that
are not ideal
um or considered misconduct because we
don't have a quorum of the board we are
not able to do the latter half so I have
about 11 complaints some of which I
would consider to be emergencies that we
have not been able to do anything with
because we don't have a board so
regardless of what you do with the
registration if you keep it something
needs to change because it's essentially
dysfunctional at this point so um I mean
if you get a complaint you consider
serious I mean could you just send it to
law enforcement or something some if
there's a criminal component yeah sure
but the person or something yeah which
is a very common complaint
um yes absolutely but of course the
standard is different it's beyond A
Reasonable Doubt as opposed to Pro you
know to um preponderance of the evidence
and secondly they're still on the
registration and there's nothing to lead
the public or
employers um to to notify them that
there's an issue with respect to
Diversion representative M yeah so they
are their own board medical correct reg
what what is the board called um the
board of registration and medical
technicians I believe is that board of
registration of medical technicians so
it's all that radiology
technician all everything it's just the
T yeah just
people yeah actually I was going to ask
that question so my younger son at one
time worked cleaning in a hospital
operating rooms in the emergency room
did he have access to control drugs
maybe he might have in the ER probably
then he might have been required to
register as a medical technician but not
here but yeah yes but he wouldn't go
around saying I'm a medical technician
that's not something that people there's
not that professional identity which is
why we have a hard time recruiting no he
called himself a fancy janitor there you
go maybe we should recruit for it I
don't
know um but okay so that I wanted to get
some idea of what so there is no board
they're not under any other board like
the nursing lnas are under nursing uh
Board of Nursing no there is a board in
statute there are no actual people to
comprise the board I think maybe we have
one person and so if you keep the
registration and it's a pure
registration I would suggest eliminating
the board and allowing the office to
handle these types of claims which is
very similar to what we do with
Opticians which doesn't have a board if
you keep the registration I mean that's
obviously a policy decision for the
legislature that we're not going to
weigh in on but I just would use I'm
using this as an opportunity explain
that there's a problem here and I don't
think it's um doing what it needs to be
doing um so we need to make some we need
to make some changes regardless okay Mr
chair certainly a followup so oplc has a
board disciplinary board for those that
you uh provide licensing or some kind of
oversight site so the way it works for
most bodies is that um the office we
investigate those were the changes that
were made last year but ultimately um
the allegations have to be brought to an
adjudicatory body which is typically a
board um The Only Exception we have is
opic dispensers and in that case it the
adjudication is done before the office
technically me I've delegated that to a
hearings officer so it's just a hearings
officer so under this scenario there is
in statute a board so we are required to
bring those cases to the board but
because there's no board there's it it's
a stop stop Gap in the process so I
would propose if you're going to keep
the registration eliminate the board
treat it as a pure registration allow
the office or hearings examiner to
adjudicate these issues because they
don't require subject matter expertise
it's typically somebody diverted drugs
or something like that that mean it's
it's it's there's no expertise required
like you you shouldn't steal drugs when
you're working in a facility so um so
that would be my suggestion if you keep
the
registration so Mr chair uh in that case
what you're saying is there's already a
practice existing corre for another
group yes just remove the board which is
not in existence it's not functioning so
you're not really damaging anything
correct and see how it goes if it gets
too much right and look at it and and I
mean I guess and where you've gotten
complaints aren't the employers aware of
this and maybe doing something or what's
going on well we're not well until it's
adjudicated we are not allowed to share
any information with anybody it's
considered confidential so it's
extremely frustrating we're holding on
to I mean we can share with law
enforcement which we do but again the
standards are very different yeah and um
even if it's criminal they may not
prosecute but if they start
investigating the employer I'd hope the
employer would get rid of them but I
would hope but then they go to the next
facility yeah I i' heard from uh you
know Senator Sherman about the whole his
whole thing is this can we add that
language and make
bill we can um we don't we'd have to get
the language um and so the proposal
would be what to do what in I think the
I think you need to consider whether you
want to eliminate the registration
completely if you do keep the bill as is
if you don't my proposal would be to
modify the bill to only eliminate the
board and allow the office to adjudicate
the disciplinary actions and we could
certainly get you that
language that is line two 22 23 24
repeal that yeah I remove that that and
we can replace it with some other
language if that's your desire
representative G and then Brown so um
sorry if we REM if we remove this
language and we keep
it no if we keep this language I'm
dyslexic oh I'm having such a hard time
with what we're what we're repealing and
removing from what but anyway um if we
stop registering janitors as medical
technicians I plain language I can do
that if we if we get a law passed so you
don't have to do
that then we're really saying that
hospitals and these other places will be
monitoring the behavior of their
employees on their correct yes thank you
thank you last question regarding this
the PO we had we had a question pending
from representative Brown uh thank you
Mr chair um uh director so I don't think
in here it removes the requirement to
register a medical TCH it does 151 3D is
is uh verifying that they're registered
not saying they have to register am I am
I wrong there well it does but if you
look at the line above it says RSA
chapter 328i which is the entire
registration process is also proposed to
be repealed okay 104 thank you and
um question yeah so was this the
situation at Portmouth
Hospital uh exitor Hospital Exit yeah so
that was a little bit different that guy
that individual was actually a
radiologic technician or um which is
actually what is regulated under the
mirt um the issue there and I will is
that I mean having worked on those cases
registration would not have prevented
this that issue because in those cases
there was ample evidence um on numerous
occasions with the other
states um where they failed to report
that information and and that's that was
the issue in that
circumstance um now if they you know the
the question remains who would they have
reported the information to um at that
point our state didn't regulate it so it
would have been an independent private
certification body that they would have
reported it to Andor law
enforcement um but that was actually a
different
profession but it but but that case was
the Genesis for this statutory change
even though this wouldn't have prevented
I'd like to make a motion which is we we
keep in the bill which would mean to
repeal from statute uh page six lines 22
I think representative G got in there
but uh all right all all in
favor all opposed okay fine all right
and then uh going um before we move on
can we clarification certainly did did
you keep those lines in or no we kept
them in the bill we kept the repeals
okay at least that's what the Comm
subcommittee will propose the full
commission got it thank
you um
okay and
then yeah and and
uh oh
sir you need to go to the mic if you're
G to ask
question somebody can give her a
space
quick you planning to keep the
registration and eliminate the board no
what this is doing was getting rid of
the whole thing okay if um you know if
somebody wanted to either put in a later
bill or amend to something
separately a a different version of it
then that could happen but that's not
discussed 10 says it's all repeal all
the listed ones are to be repealed so we
are repealing the first three 22 23 24
and representative Brown yes I I believe
the director said if if we repeal the
board of registration that that also
includes repealing the Reg
Administration correct because it's in
the the entire chapter thank you all
right and then I have a a question for
oplc about um what so there there are
the repeals in here related to Medical
Imaging and and radiation therapy yes um
which one of these all these repeals are
related to that so that would be line 20
uh 25 and
26 25 is the entire chapter yeah so so
as proposed you would just be
eliminating The Lure requirement and
then 26 is just the reference to a board
in our statute 310 which would no longer
exist if eliminated by 328j and are the
are all of the things in here related to
326b all related to lnas or correct um
well I would say I think I think it's
worth going unfortunately line by line
because some of the changes are cleanup
changes you know the the ones regarding
fees the office has the authority um to
assess fees so if if the leg if if the
committee wanted to address the cleanup
issues still in this bill you would want
to go line by line I'll go through it
and get you that language by Monday yeah
um so I I know there was a whole lot of
um concern about getting rid of the
licensing of Medical Imaging and
radiation therapy and I know you may not
be able to say or no but what was the
impetus behind that why was that viewed
as unnecessary if you
know so my understanding is that that
was created around the time that medical
technicians were
created and when when looking and again
I'm not taking a position and there are
others I think who can speak to exactly
um you know the professional
requirements um but
they're not not every
modality
is regulated in every state and the
um gist of it you know is a is a belief
that regulation or Public Safety can um
be ensured through private
certification that's the gist okay and
is there any current requirement for
private certification or would that have
to be added if the state wanted a
require as oppos the
employer um well I don't know that would
be interesting I don't know how the
state would
mandate I think You' probably have to do
it through facility regulations to say
if you're going to be licensed you have
to ensure that somebody in this position
has has to be um nationally certified
but under the previous model that New
Hampshire had which is no regulation it
was up to the employer so right now for
medical imaging and radiation therapy is
that a license or a registration it's a
license okay um and what are the
requirements like is it basically they
have to have this certification some
nationally recognized thing is there
much more typically they have to have a
national certification yes but other
than paying the fee and maybe a
background check there's the criminal
history check is a component as well
yeah right but I mean there's is there
any other
is there a board that comes up with
specific criteria and all that for this
yeah and I do know we have a member of
The Advisory Board in in the audience
yeah I was just trying to get the
structure yes questions
there yeah um before you know we get too
much further so I just want to do a
little overview of the rest of this um
section 10 so we already uh asked uh Mr
R house to get us a list of the repeals
that are related to the LNA since we're
not repealing the lnas he said he' get
us the ones that we need to remove out
of here you said there's some that are
from I mean there those the three we
dealt with there's the two for the
radiation thing there's um some you said
are cleanup and you're going to get me a
list of which ones are those and we can
look at them um and then
um are there any other repeals Rel I'd
like to get through this first and part
of it is um I want to talk about a plan
on how to go forward and R Brown needs
to leave at
3:40 um and doesn't say we have to end
then but at least I want to see where we
can
get um so are any of the other repeals
related to anything else yeah okay so
here here's what i' like to propose to
the subcommittee I mean we can the
people are here from um the uh radiation
therapy and Medical Imaging and we can
hear from them um but but and I thank
people for that and I apologize it's a
big bill with a lot of pieces
um my feeling given you know the
testimony we heard is
that there's probably not an appetite to
repeal this and so what I'm thinking
where we'll probably go but it's going
to be up to the subcommittee is to and
we can hear from people first although
they may be happy just if we do this but
to repeal those two SE ctions Rel you
know related to the uh you know lines 25
and 26 on page six rep repeal I'm sorry
I should say that wrong language problem
we will remove them from the Bill thank
you and so the we will no longer repeal
them and that's what we're talking about
doing um yeah and maybe we could make we
might make a motion but I like to go
through the rest of this and then um we
need we're going to get from
oplc uh two lists one is the repeals
that are related to the LNA thing
because we're going to add those to
things removed from the
bill and then there's the other ones
that are related to cleanup and so what
I would propose is that um you know if
they get that to us let's say on Monday
that I schedule a 9:00 am subcommittee
meeting before a regular meeting and all
we'll have to do is
um you know well I'll look at the time I
might be able to get an actual there's
two things we need to do one is we need
to look over the um the cleanup ones to
see if we have an issue with them and
and vote on that um we can take I think
I'm take a vote before uh BR Brown has
to leave on the medical imagine um I
know when people you can still ask
questions of them if you want but I
think we heard enough I've got enough
documentation that I think that's what
we're going to do um and then uh we'll
meet I'll talk to car about scheduling
we'll meet at 9: one morning and and go
over that and then um and and I'll have
the list of things be the things removed
from the bill around LNA we can vote on
that and then I'll have a list of stuff
and I and I'll write this out and
organize it and that I will then submit
to OLS to get a am an amendment and then
I'll you know consult with Carol the
question is do we need to meet again
which would again be a short meeting in
the morning um to actually vote to
accept this or is it good enough that we
voted our
intent and then just deal with the real
Amendment before the full committee is
that anybody have an issue with any of
that I'd like to suggest we vote the
intent with the understanding that we
will see the actual written Amendment
certainly before it comes up in okay
well in that case we would meet as a
subcommittee to vote on the amendment
which I'm fine with but can't we vote on
it and as long as when we look at it
before the committee meeting it looks
like what
wean
what when I get it out of os I'm going
to send it to everybody yeah and I mean
for your help to look at it it's like
did I miss something or did OS miss
something which I've certainly seen
happen so I need your help on that but
the question and then certainly if you
let me know there's a problem and that's
a technical thing something was left out
then I can go back to OS um but once we
have one that we're happy with then
there's a process question which my
question is what do we need to do and
the other question is what do you folks
want want to do um you know we could
have then a short subcommittee meeting
to formally vote to accept the actual
Amendment which I'm okay with or if
everybody's okay not doing that and we
don't have to then it'll depend on the
timing and when we have to execute all I
mean that's I'm flexible on all that but
uh I just want to make sure everybody is
happy with the end result trying to be
clear I'd be happier to vote now on the
medical
imaging on the whole well we did it in
we did it in pieces
and so I'd be happy to leave here with
an overall vote we don't have to meet
again on it
as when we get here here's the here's
the problem excuse me representative put
put your microphone on for
the here's the problem with that yeah
the problem is that there are some of
the repeals that are not related to
anything we've discussed and voted on
but are related to some general opl soid
cleanup now sometimes you have things
that are called cleanup and they
actually have real effects that maybe
we'd want to consider and so what I I
wouldn't be feel Comfort I wouldn't feel
comfortable okay so i' want us to at
least meet um and when we have the list
we'll just have a some list hopefully
small of these items in section 10 that
we need to review and and if we're
comfortable with all of them fine and
then we'll we'll vote to accept them
okay um but that's the only part we
won't have voted on so I'd like to make
a motion right now that um we
uh we remove from the bill uh page six
lines 25 and 26 which are the ones
related to Medical Imaging and radiation
therapy and if I can get a actually I'd
like to ask someone to make that motion
reasons why I'll make that motion okay
that means we are not addressing that
right now actually um we um and U ba we
we are addressing it in the sense where
saying we're going to take it out of the
bill and therefore we will leave that
Licensing in place so yeah we are
dealing with it and Mr chair M yeah
represent I'm just hoping that we can
hear from I'll be glad because this is
in final and you know we're going to
take another vote and so and people came
up here yeah but I want to accom I want
to get I don't want to have to have
another full meeting right and I'd like
to accommodate representative Brown I
think we I couldn't we couldn't yes all
right so any further discussion on this
motion my question is can we just have
them nod their heads if they like this
is is there anybody here who is opposed
to leaving that Licensing in here yay
thank you thank you Mr CH the good point
that's a good idea all
right uh yeah the second was repres
Bailey
um okay I'm going to go person by person
because I'm going to vote no on this
although which is fine I'm going to lose
I'm okay okay with that so uh represent
mapy to leave it
in oh yeah well I mean if you're not
ready and you want more things I'm fine
I mean we don't we don't have to vote
right now I don't want to push they will
still be licensed if you vote
Yes
okay okay uh representative G yes oh
representative
Bailey okay that's a yes yes
Bailey representative
brown
brown there's a yes I'm going to be a no
and that's
fine not the first time I've lost a vote
and that's the only two uh those are the
only two lines I mean as I we've dealt
with the three above it on the medical
Technic
registration and we still have to get
details on which ones we need to remove
from the bill related to because we left
s a in licensing and then what are the
ones we need to actually look at because
they're for cleanup a quick question
about to op
oplc yeah which is the board under which
this Medical Imaging and radiation
therapy comes out somebody has a
question if you come up
wait yeah what's sure qu let me I said I
want to know if they have a board like
the other one they didn't have a board
that was functioning okay re uh uh
exective director yeah we have a
functioning board it this board is an
Advisory Board um which is a little bit
different but they are fully functioning
and provide the necessary guidance and
show up and do what they need to do
thank thank you whoever had a question
please come to the mic introduce
yourself and ask your
question than Mr chairman uh Tom prol
from Demmer and praw I represent the new
kampire Society for radiologic
technologist I just wanted to uh bring
to your attention mention that if you
were going to remove the repeals in
section 10 you might want to address the
uh cross out in uh section 9 actually as
that's the only thing in section N9 so
let's reopen that motion if the if the
maker and the second are okay um and we
will include in that removing um all of
section
n
um uh I think well by removing I'm sorry
removing section n from the bill will
leave statute unchanged right which will
just take out those two strikeouts I'm
I'm sorry representative section 9 also
includes the medical technicians I think
you still would have to okay which one
is which uh three I think I is medical
technicians and J is medical IM okay so
let me change it so this would also be
to remove RSA
DJ from section nine in the bill and and
leave in right and and leave well but if
my motion is just on on on pulling R
removing that from the
repeal right if we your Mo I mean we're
adding to the motion to remove
328i from section N9 and that's the one
around radiation J right is radiation
all right Che so we sorry I got my notes
Here wrong I'm not reading my own notes
wrong one had it right did so we're
going to remove the the we're going to
remove the removal of the reference to
328 J from section nine
where what page in
line I'm sorry page oh page five no no
page six yep
line I mean four and five line four and
five are Rel related to imaging
technology uh no no which I'm I'm I'm
confused we're on
page that's what I
needed r no no no that's 25 and 26
that's what the motion is on you just
said
328j right we're adding that to the
motion but to remove we're voting to
we're voting to remove from the bill and
correct me if I'm wrong y uh um the
repeal of 328j and the repeal of 3102
Roman 2D correct and we're removing from
the bill the removal of 328j on line 18
yes okay which refers to the radio so
yes we are that was am I correct that
the uh representative ghoul the maker of
the motion representative Bailey II
agree with that change and are any of
the votes different every everybody's
Yes except me is
that oh yes okay and um I mean we can
still talk to people we want but um he
he's saying we don't need to so I'm I'm
I'm going to close here and I want to
thank everybody in this committee for
working great together on this
complicated
mess and all the people who came went to
the trouble of driving up through
whatever it is now I hope it's not ice I
know um uh to come and help us with this
and and uh thank you and subcommittees
if it works I'll run it less formally
but with somewhat somewhat under control
all right
a yeah I know and I'm okay with that I
mean he sent me a note when he had to
leave so I was trying to at least get
the main work done
yes thank you very much and everybody
have a safe drive back please we don't
anybody I saw your
picture I was I was tell you I've got a
friend of mine uh Amy day who also
purch